foreign
[Music]
the short walk to the stage can be a
time for artists to reflect
[Music]
to remember the path it took to get here
can be intoxicating
[Music]
quiet fills the room
and then that first note
[Music]
[Applause]
you may not know him yet but if music
matters to you you should
like magical
unnamable thing that some artists have
and that's what Evan has
[Applause]
[Music]
borne Evan Pang he now performs under
the name a sanabi his debut album
featuring The Single Nomads has caught
fire getting airtime on radio stations
that haven't traditionally supported
indigenous artists
foreign
there's something about him that's
captivating audiences he played more
than a hundred shows last year and even
Europe has begun to take notice
[Music]
but if this sounds like an overnight
success story it isn't there were plenty
of hurdles to overcome
I was up a bit late last night can you
tell
the year was 2020 back then he was still
just Evan and during the pandemic he had
a daily ritual speaking with his
grandfather Watton the zoom calls to
Watson's Thunder Bay Care Home would
take Evan back in time he is my last at
the time the last direct connection to
like my my you know our roots and where
we come from in our family
Evan started recording those phone calls
to preserve his grandfather's stories
what he learned from Watson's dark
memories of the residential school
experience would stay with him and
through watton's voice he found his own
which he set to music
yeah I was just actually listening kind
of noodling on the guitar when I was
listening back to these recordings just
like you know that room over there and
just wrote a song and
and then wrote another song and then I
thought like this is how I can like
save some of the story and this is how I
can like immortalize the story a little
bit and the irony is is that what ended
up becoming your breakthrough is you
stopped making music for other people
you started making music that you wanted
for yourself yeah when you you're
looking for something for for a while
and then you stop looking for it and
suddenly it just kind of shows up right
[Music]
I didn't grow up in a traditional room
my grandparents were taken when they
were kids and put into residential
school
Evan is OG Cree from Sandy Lake First
Nation he moved off the Reserve at age
three and his mother gave him the last
name Pang
it would just be easier she believed for
him to have a non-indigenous name
he discovered a passion for music
spending countless hours mastering the
guitar
[Music]
and as a teenager moved into a house
with other musicians for a time it was
perfect he worked during the day and
played music at night until the morning
he went to make a cup of coffee and
found someone in his kitchen smoking
crack
Evan knew right then he had to find a
different path
[Music]
a young man in search of his identity
and direction in life Evan was working
as a surveyor in the mining industry
he'd spend months in the bush hiking
Often by himself
and then on a cold February day
everything changed
it was just snowshoeing across the river
and like I just broke through the ice
I could just feel the river kind of
pulling my legs
my snow pants were just filling up and I
have snowshoes on so I know if I could
go under I can't even swim
I just remember like crawling across
this and like
one actually at a time and like the ice
kept breaking and I was just like like
what am I doing with my life
[Music]
he survived made a fire to dry off
and on his 13 kilometer walk back to
Camp considered how to realize his dream
of becoming a musician
how long after that did you quit I had a
plane ticket and I was gone in three
months
[Music]
[Applause]
Toronto and all its promise beckoned
he was drawn to its lights and music
scene
[Music]
he saw an ad for the international
indigenous music Summit and while he
wanted to play he didn't want to pay the
sign up fee but how about this Oddity
he had 10 bucks in a crypto exchange and
on a lark invested it in a fledgling
currency called wait for it
ass coin yeah ass coin and guess what it
went up 2 800 percent that day
I owe my whole career to ask him yet
it was actually called ask
Evan as you may have guessed sold on the
high
and use the windfall to apply to the
summit was it just good luck or fate
coin story yes that's got to be the
strangest Story I mean it's pretty funny
it's pretty funny I just this has all
been begging to happen is what I really
think yeah the universe yeah
Amanda rayom and shashona Kish founded
the international indigenous music
Summit five years ago to give exposure
to undiscovered talent in their
community
they get hundreds of fantastic
submissions every year
[Music]
Evans was next level
we both were just like who is this how
have we never seen this or heard this
before it just stopped us in our tracks
[Music]
shoshona and Amanda had just launched
ishkide records the first female owned
indigenous record label they needed
something great to get going and out of
nowhere came Evan
he's tapping into something really
powerful once in a while there is just
an energy around an artist and it's just
snowballed so quickly I mean there are a
lot of artists that do very well and
they sort of stay within Canada do you
see him yeah bro shaking your head no oh
yeah he's
yeah
you know traveling around the world it's
not a stretch to say both label and
artists were looking for a match
I feel like we're sort of
being pulled down a path more than like
designing it ourselves
[Music]
path has been undeniably Rocky but he
found his voice
the one last thing he needed was to
reclaim his identity when I was going to
put out the record I just thought I'd
put out under Ace and Abby you know it's
my grandfather's name it's my family
name this painting of his grandfather
Watton remains one of his most cherished
possessions it hangs in his home and
Graces the cover of his album their
connection is undeniable and now it's
preserved in the music
[Music]
memories
we made this beautiful record together
and you know I have a lot of
so much to him him being watching again
you know and me being a Snappy and
finding ourselves and who we are and
it's like wow like our story doesn't
just disappear now
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign